un destin comme je vous remercie la
parole est à madame bérengère poletti
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre vous connaissez la
situation des collectivités
territoriales et tout particulièrement
celle des conseils départementaux
elle est dramatique l'asphyxient
budgétaires augmentent chaque année avec
la baisse des dotations mais aussi et
surtout parce que vous ne compensait pas
les dépenses sociales
pire vous faites de la politique sur le
dos des départements vous décidé
d'augmenter le rsa mais ce sont les
départements qui paye vous décidé de
modifier la pas mais ce sont toujours
les départements qui paye c'est facile
de dépenser l'argent des autres
non seulement vous détourner les moyens
des départements à votre profit mais
vous l'avez fait aussi sur le dos des
français en particulier des retraités
avec une nouvelle taxe la casa
normalement mise en place pour aider les
personnes âgées elle ne l'aura pas
profité pendant plus de deux ans vous
avez ainsi détourné plus d'un milliard
d'euros
ensuite vous essayer de nous faire
croire à nos concitoyens que la loi
vieillissement de bonal rossignol est
entièrement compensés par l'état
c'est complètement faux dans les
ardennes la dépense supplémentaire
financé par l'état et imposé par votre
gouvernement se monte à plus de 2
millions d'euros pour 2017
mais cela ne vous dérange pas vous vous
permettez en plus de faire la leçon aux
départements qui sont étranglés par vos
décisions
plus grave encore vous parler d'une loi
révolutionnaire alors que pour les
personnes âgées admises en établissement
vous n'avez strictement rien fait avec
le gouvernement de françois fillon vous
nous avions consacré beaucoup de moyens
aux établissements pour les moderniser
pour les médicalisé
contrairement il vous plaît monsieur 1er
mai
east les gouvernements socialistes
successifs
encore une fois n'ont pas été à la
hauteur de leurs promesses et s'est dit
la parole et à madame pascale boitard
secrétaire d'état chargée des personnes
âgées et de l'autonomie merci monsieur
le président madame la députée bérengère
et il vous plaît allez on écoute la
réponse calmement il y a les 10e et les
faisons et si je prends le précédent
quinquennat ya eu beaucoup de discours
sur la dépendance et les personnes âgées
émeutes du cinquième risque
mais malheureusement aucun texte n'est
venu prendre en compte le vieillissement
de la population
ce texte eh bien nous nous l'avons fait
comme l'engagement présidentiel l'avait
prévu et nous le réalisons aujourd'hui
et les départements ceux qui l'ont
souhaité sont aujourd'hui ses pilotes de
cette nouvelle politique publique depuis
le mois d'avril 2000 16 740 millions
d'euros ont été confiées au département
dont un demi milliard pour la
revalorisation de l'apa depuis avril
vous pouvez revalorisée chaque situation
de personnes âgées parce que cette loi
nous avons mis l'humain au coeur de
cette loi avec l'ensemble des
professionnels et j'étais encore ce
matin avec des professionnels alors
madame poletti je sais que vous êtes
frustrés parce que vous avez fait une
mission parlementaire que vous avez
commandé madame bachelot que vous avez
remis en janvier 2012 peut-être pour
justifier le fait que vous avez un peu
réfléchi à cette question dans cette
mandature
mais là contraire c'est que nous nous
l'avons fait et lorsque vous parlez de
détournement je vous le dis ce sont des
termes très grave et c'est un 9 sens
démocratique où siègent
l'adf qui en ce moment prend en charge
des avocats dans des départements pour
défendre des départements qui
n'appliquent pas la loi
et ça je trouve ça scandaleux alors
madame politi vous êtes parent parole de
votre parti politique vous peut-être que
vous défendez aujourd'hui le le cumul
des mandats vous défendez aujourd'hui le
fait qu'il n'y aura pas de parité dans
les candidatures merci madame l'ap